so this is all by by way of saying not
only is the metric system demonic uh but
cause and effect is made up
um in the Middle Ages people did not see
history and again you could read some of
Van alaskan's essays about this and he's
even got a whole section on it in a
history of the island that people are
curious about this but in the Middle
Ages people didn't see history as a
series of causes and effects they saw
history as a battle between good and
evil
which means that
the most important thing in history has
already happened
because that was the crucifixion and the
resurrection of Jesus Christ yeah right
but history is this battle between good
and evil this is what the whole
Apocalypse of Saint John is about is
history seen as this conflict between
good and evil in which good ultimately
triumphs
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so hello everyone I am back with Richard
Roland for another Universal history
episode uh this week Richard is going to
give us a presentation that he's
prepared in another context but that is
very I was very successful it is about
how to read like a medieval how to look
at the ancient world how to read the
text how to engage with the ancient
world in a way that's truthful for us
today and before we start I just want to
make sure you know about the Beowulf
class that we are putting together
Richard is going to give a a Christian
reading of Beowulf that we're going to
have on the symbolic World Community I
will be part of it I will be taking the
class and also giving some comments in
the discussion and so look at the
description uh there'll be a link in the
description below
um and we would love to see you come in
this is a new thing we're doing and
we're really excited about this
possibility of diving in way more than
what we do in just these podcasts and
and helping you learn how exactly like
what we're talking about today how to
read these old texts how to make them
relevant to you today so Richard kick us
off all right well thanks Jonathan I'm
very excited about both the Beowulf
class which is I mean there's
I think I've said this before on this on
this podcast but if if I could if I had
to just have one book that is the only
book I could study and talk about for
the rest of my life you know this is
setting aside the holy Scriptures it
would probably be Beowulf um so there's
there's nothing that I'm more excited to
talk about and to get to talk about it
with you and about with all the people
who have signed up to be a part of the
class and a part of the live discussion
everything else it's going to be great
you guys can go to the symbolic world uh
store I think there's a link there where
you can we can get signed up for the
class so uh but what we're talking about
today uh this is a talk that I gave at
uh father photos Parish Saint sava's
Orthodox Church here in uh Allen Texas
um so shout out to Father fodius who I
know listens to these uh uh listens
listens to to the universal history
episodes
um and his family uh uh they were
wonderful they they you know really
great church really Dynamic Parish uh if
you can ever if you're ever in the north
Texas area and you can check out and
support the work they're doing there I
think it's just incredible he has one of
the most like I would say medieval
churches in the area in terms of the way
that they've built their building and
laid out the interior and the art and
the iconography that they're doing now
it's just fantastic
um but so this is a talk that I gave as
a fundraiser for his parish and a lot of
people asked for a recording it wasn't
really recorded then but I wanted to do
it now in the context of the the
universal history uh discussion because
one of the questions that I get the most
often is something like okay but how do
we actually read these stories like and
see the things that you guys are seeing
when you're when you're talking about
them basically like well how do I do
this at home how do I tell my kids about
this stuff right when my kid asks the
questions question you know okay but did
dragons really exist or you know okay
this thing happens in a saint story but
did they really do that like how do I
how do I answer that question for them
and uh so what I wanted to do was try it
was was to actually kind of pull back
the curtain a little bit it's going to
be a little bit of an apocalyptic
episode this time and just talk about
some of the underlying assumptions or
the underlying understandings that we
use when we read these old stories
um and the way that we read them and
maybe that'll help people kind of move
in that direction so
um I wanted to start with a a quote from
C.S Lewis which is the which is where
all Orthodox converts uh American
Orthodox converts have to begin
everything is with a C.S Lewis quote
um this is in his essay de addendius
poetis he says there are two ways of
enjoying the past as there are two ways
of enjoying a foreign country one man
carries his carries his English re
abroad with him and brings it home
unchanged we could say like his
americanness now because I think
Americans have displaced the English as
like the worst tourists but anyway
um wherever he goes he consorts with the
other in English tourists by a good
hotel he means one that is like an
English Hotel he complains that the bad
tea where he might have had excellent
coffee he finds the natives quaint and
enjoys their quaintness in the same way
there is a man who carries his modernity
with him through all his reading of past
literatures and preserved it preserves
it intact the highlights in all ancient
and medieval poetry are for him the bits
that resemble or can be so read that
they seem to resemble the Poetry of his
own age
but there's another sort of traveling
and another sort of reading you can eat
the local food
and drink the local wines you can share
the four in life you can begin to see
the foreign country as it looks not to
the tourist but to its inhabitants you
can come home modified thinking and
feeling as you did not think and feel
before
so with old literature you can go beyond
the first impressions that a poem makes
on your modern Sensibility
by study of things outside the poem by
comparing it with other poems by
steeping yourself in the vanished period
you can be then re-enter the poem with
eyes more like those of the natives
and so the premise uh that sort of like
kicks off this our discussion today
is that um
the situation for us as Christians
should be that the world is a foreign
country right uh Saint Peter says I urge
you as sojourners and Exiles I think the
King James says strangers and aliens to
abstain from the passions of the flesh
which wage war against your soul
um
the world should be a foreign place to
us but for most of us especially those
of us who are moving out of a modern
context back towards some more
traditional form of Christianity
right uh it's usually the reverse we've
we come to the church finding it as a
foreign country and uh actually I would
even say uh for instance you don't hear
it actually very often anymore but one
of the the sometimes one of the
objections that I'll hear when somebody
uh visits an Eastern Orthodox church for
the first time is something like oh well
it's just it's too Eastern it's too
difficult for the Western mind to
understand et cetera Etc as though
there's something like hard-coded into
the Western brain you know that can't
understand people going in and out of
doors or something you know it's like a
little it's like what what do you really
mean but but but but what they're really
saying though and people people don't
realize this but what they're really
saying is it's not modern enough yeah
right it's not an East-West thing
um and I've I've you know I've said many
times and I I will keep saying it until
I'm blue in the face that the real
difference isn't East versus West it's
modern versus ancient yeah right
um so we we come as modern people
encountering a a pre-modern church a
pre-modern holy tradition and actually
listen even if you're a Protestant
you've got no interest in becoming
Eastern Orthodox or traditional Roman
Catholic or something like that the very
fact that you have the Holy scriptures
right which which is a pre-modern you
know text or a series of pre-modern
texts it is something which is actually
not written for you now all scripture is
written for you because it's scripture
just like the Liturgy is always for you
because it's the Liturgy but you weren't
the original audience right
um and and it was something that was
created uh you know
through human tools and those people
that wrote those things were not uh for
instance
they were not 21st century Americans uh
one time uh when I was uh I was teaching
this is my old church before we became
Orthodox I was teaching a family uh we
had a sort of a family integrated Bible
study so like an all ages Sunday school
basically it's this one of the things
that I did uh it was a great class by
the way love those people love that
class it was so fun uh and but one of
the one you know we're going through
some of the Psalms and so we come to
some of these like the Royal Psalms the
Psalms that have to do with like the
King right and I just said hey guys just
to like you know just to uh because I'm
an agent of Chaos in the world I just I
just you know I was like I was like Hey
guys so uh you know as we get into this
we're gonna read the psalm and it's
about you know God Save the King right
that's what the psalm is about and then
at the end uh I said
um now
having read the psalm what would you
guys say the most biblical
form of government is
and everyone in the class I mean there's
like 40 people in this class everyone
said oh obviously it's a representative
Republic
you know not even a democracy they said
representative Republican Republic is a
good good American conservatives but um
but but I mean this is just I mean this
is it's a little still a bit silly of an
example but it's a classic example of
sort of taking our frame and trying to
take it to the way that we read the
scriptures right
um and so because we do this because
we're like that first kind of tourist
right we fail to realize that the holy
that Holy tradition so the scripture the
Liturgy the doctor and the moral law of
the church
um that we've received was never
intended to satisfy our tastes so when
we encounter things that are sort of
quaint we're like oh isn't that nice
they used to believe that and when we
encounter things that we don't like it's
because they're too strange or they're
too regressive or they're too Eastern or
what have you
um and so the point of actually this
Soul uh this whole project I would say
the the entire project of my adult life
has been to help people be the good kind
of tourist right several people have
said you know in the discussion around
the universal history videos well
obviously you can't just turn your your
mind and you're you like you can't wind
back the clock you can't just become a
13th century Russian peasant as much as
maybe you would like to do and that's
that's true that's true but you could at
least start by becoming the good kind of
tourist yeah and so the idea is to is to
kind of shift from seeing the church and
the scriptures as a foreign country to
seeing it as our home right that all of
these things including the holy
scriptures are foreign to us in the
sense that they're pre-modern that
they're Eastern
you know the Psalms were not written you
know
in you know Kentucky
um
they're ancient they're hierarchical
we're modern we're post-modern we're
obsessed with up to the minute relevance
with being egalitarian and so when we
try to Wrangle with tradition by
adjusting it or rebalancing it for
modern day sensibilities
um
uh uh instead of encountering it for
what it is then it it you know we end up
doing violence to it right yeah and it's
also like there's also something to say
that's important which is that the
modern world has been the world in which
Society has moved away from its faith
has moved away from its attachment you
know to to scripture to to Faith and so
it's not surprising that in a world that
was set up
the day that brought us away from faith
in that world it would be more difficult
for us to understand the the the vehicle
by which Faith was brought into into the
west and so it we have to kind of humble
ourselves and be careful because one of
the problems that happens is that
in the modern world you have two
reactions you have a kind of modernism
that uses modern tools like science like
you know a kind of materialism a kind of
rationalism to destroy the past and then
you have strange people that still
Embrace rationalism and materialism and
a kind of that kind of attitude but then
use the very tools to try to defend
rights that were never meant to be that
in the first place yes uh my own
childhood is I mean I grew up in like a
really hard line uh uh uh younger
creationists like literalist uh reading
of Genesis right where basically like
they'll they'll take certain lines in
Genesis and try to like twist them to
conform to sort of hear some Fringe
scientific theory right and there's a
whole discussion to be had around this
let's say
um I certainly believe God is the maker
of all things visible and invisible and
uh uh really strongly uh there's
something deep in my core that reacts
against the myth of evolutionism right
but uh the problem with this approach is
the way in which it subjects the
scriptures to science actually what both
what both like the new atheists and the
and the the younger you know uh Answers
in Genesis and those folks what they
both agree on is that science is the
standard yeah I've heard people say
science is the mind of God like in
church
seeing the mind of God and I was like
yeah I I mean I was like 17 and I was
already like uh I don't know about that
that's not that's really that's not good
yeah that's not great okay so uh anyway
we want to help people be at least begin
as being the second kind of visitor the
second kind of tourist so that when we
come to the church the Liturgy and to
the scriptures uh we encounter them not
as some kind of a foreign country that
needs to change and conform to the
culture that we came from but actually
as our true home right as the Soul's
true home so uh a one way to kind of
um
frame this would be to say uh is to
think in terms of mirrors mirrors and
windows right uh that ancient literature
and ancient liturgy could either be
a mirror that reflects our own faces
back to us where we sort of see the
things we're looking for
or it could be a window through which we
gaze upon
Paradise upon the Stars upon the
Heavenly City upon the love that moves
the sun and the other stars as Dante
would say right and so that's kind of
the goal here is to cultivate this I'll
explain this at the end but this
mystogogical vision of the cosmos so
this being said uh there are four things
that I would put forward as these are
shifts you must make if you're going to
read any ancient literature let's say
let's say pre-modern literature because
it's it's really ancient and medieval
right so if you're going to read any
pre-modern literature and really read it
charitably there are kind of four shifts
that you kind of have to adopt
so the first is a shift in the way that
we think about authorship and
originality yeah um and this is where uh
this is where a lot of the damage was
done before people realized what was
happening
um starting in the 19th century
so we have this we have this discipline
called signed uh called sexual criticism
um and uh on its own it's just a set of
tools for figuring out when something
was written and who wrote it
um and so in that sense you know like
like many tools it could be used in a
good way I have you know in my in my own
academic career I have engaged in
textual criticism specifically in and
around Old Norse poetry
um uh and actually some version of this
has existed since the ancient world
right famously origin you know one of
the most important you know his most
important contributions to the tradition
was essentially worked of textual
criticism uh looking you know comparing
the Septuagint to the Hebrew Old
Testament right
um
people have always known that there were
difficulties presented by manuscripts
and that manuscripts contradicted each
other like people weren't stupid
um it's true that literacy rates were
generally lower although not as low as
people sometimes think they were but
people who were illiterate read a lot
more than we do today like we live in a
post-literate society where we think we
can read because we can read like a
tweet or a an X I don't even know what
we call them anymore
um uh but like we think we're literate
because we can read like a status update
or you know a headline or something like
that but actually most of us just read
two sentences and we skip to the next
paragraph when we read those first two
sentences and so on right we're actually
sort of post-literate but uh people who
could read in pre-modern times read
deeply they read deeply so they noticed
these differences they noticed way more
differences actually sometimes I'll be
reading along like in in the you know um
something like the ambigua which is all
about these difficulties in you know
written by Saint Maximus or something
like that some some text like I'll be
reading along anybody like ah now here
we clearly have what what appears to be
a a difference between this gospel
writer and this gospel right and I'm
looking and I'm like well it doesn't
really actually seem like is a
difference to me right they were much
more precise in in the ways that they
look for these things so people always
knew and people always understood that
that there were things like translation
errors copyist errors right which could
render a phrase difficult to understand
but the pre-modern Mind saw these
difficulties as being providential
actually as as uh an indication that
there is some deeper meaning the reader
was intended by the Holy Spirit to
unearth it's like uh it's like the uh
say like like the corner of a treasure
chest poking up out of the ground and
you walk along you trip across it and
then you notice oh there's some buried
treasure right here yeah but and and I
and I want to defend that very precisely
for people because people might think
that it's just a cope uh you know and I
think that you can actually structurally
you can understand it which is that
imagine uh a story that you tell and
that you have to remember and one of the
things that makes you help remember a
story is it's just general coherence
it's like if it makes sense then you
remember it better like if it makes
sense then you can attend to it more
easily but the fact that in stories that
are very ancient certain quirky details
that are are so weird are maintained in
the story means that there had to be
great effort to to remember that you
know and so I I mentioned that for
example like in in a very simple one
that has nothing to do with like the
with scripture itself but in for example
in Translation uh about texts about
Saint Christopher there was this weird
change that happened between the idea of
Canaanite like from Canaan and then
Kanan like in terms of dog Canaanites in
terms of dog and and the the people
interpreting it says well it's all
ridiculous because it's just a mistake
in transcription but if if someone had
made a mistake in transcription and that
mistaken transcription made absolutely
no sense it would have been corrected in
the next iteration but if there's
something about it that is holding then
maybe that that that mistake is then
continued on mistake it's not a mistake
it is something like a providential
transformation of the text and so we it
I know it's hard for people to
understand that if things are remembered
and intended to even though they're
weird it means there's something hidden
underneath it and so that's what that's
how the church fathers would see it it's
like there's some weird detail that's so
strange that doesn't seem to make sense
like why is it there if it's maintained
there
and uh this is actually I mean the the
best example for this is just to
understand this is why we have four
gospels not one I mean it actually sort
of is the one gospel right but it but we
have four gospel accounts let me put it
that way yeah um so actually it's not
the first book of the New Testament it's
not Matthew it is The Gospel According
to Saint Matthew right um this is how
it's said liturgically and even when I
speak about it in like teaching class
and things like that I always try to use
that precise language because it's the
one gospel and in fact we collect all
four accounts into a single book in the
Orthodox Church which we call the gospel
book which we we parade around and we
kiss and we venerate we read from and
everything so it's the one gospel right
this verbal icon of Christ is how the
fathers speak of it but we have four
accounts and those four accounts have
these sort of subtle differences
sometimes major differences but
um there were attempts actually even
quite early on to create a single
harmonized gospel account you notations
uh attempt is the most famous but a lot
of people tried this and actually the
church rejected it
right the church rejected it um if we
wanted just a single synthesized smooth
account
we could have had it right we could have
kept it we could have just picked one of
the four gospels at any given point time
or we could have made our own you know
our own version that you know smoothed
out all the differences included all the
parts if we wanted that we could have
had it but it was not God's Will and it
was not you know what the church agreed
upon to have that we have four gospel
accounts and some of these gospel
accounts have subtle differences
actually if you look at
um I'll I'll tease something which I
won't pay off and so people will have to
go dig themselves for it
um as as as I think uh you know this is
this is this is how Christ teaches so I
there's precedent for it
um so the thing that I'll tease did not
pay off is that if you go and look at
the account of how the murder bearing
women come to the Tomb in the synoptic
gospels it's uh it's a little bit
different in each version and the list
of who's there and who's not there and
the timing Mary Magdalene coming and and
the apostles it's all just like there
are these little subtle differences
but if you go and you read for instance
Saint Greg of palomas's homilies on
these texts
on the resurrection there is actually a
really beautiful mystery that Saint
Gregory and actually other Church
fathers saw uh as being hidden as sort
of being hidden there within the gospels
concerning
um concerning the resurrection and the
mother of God so I won't explain what
that is but I'll encourage people to go
out and kind of research it for
themselves okay
so the the so this is this is like one
commonplace example but you could
basically say if you wanted to boil down
uh this this pretty modern approach to
authorship you could say uh that they
that they approached it this way first
of all they approached reading with
credulity credulity that is they believe
that the author loves you
uh because producing a book is an act of
love right books are extremely expensive
in the ancient world they they create
they they represent
um not just a lot of time and training
that would have to go into somebody
skilled enough to produce a book but
also like the the Lost Economic
Opportunity because most books are
written on the on the on the skins of
young animals right sheep and and cattle
specifically well
if I kill a young calf that's a calf
that's now out of my breeding pool I
can't ever get meat from that calf I
can't ever get milk from that you know I
can't get any of that stuff right
um so he presents a tremendous like lost
opportunity
um and so this is actually why for
instance as you and if you look at
Medieval text the farther north you go
um in other words the poor people get
and the the more uh scarce like animals
become uh the more abbreviations are
used in the texts and so by the time you
get to Iceland it's like they have an
abbreviation for almost every word it's
a total nightmare like if you read like
you know you know stuff you know uh
written on the continent it's in this
beautiful Carolinian minuscule and it's
super legible and you can basically just
read it off the page and then you look
at something that's happening like 600
years later in Iceland and it's almost
completely illegible unless you have a
magnifying glass why because they're
trying to save paper right they're
trying to save paper so
um
creating a book is an act of love
the pre-modern approach to reading is
first of all this with an assumption
that the author loves you and then the
assumption that the Holy Spirit has
guided the process not only of
composition which the the sort of
fundamentalist world that I grew up in
are really big on this the Holy Spirit
has guided the process of the
composition of the scriptures although
in the Middle Ages they would have
actually said this is true for all good
books
um it's especially true for scripture
but it's true for all good books but
um the holy spirit is guided not only
the process of composition but also that
of transmission
right so that the Bible that you have is
the Bible that you have
not some easier version of the Bible not
some version of the Bible that you would
have made to satisfy like modern
questions and concerns uh because that's
what the Holy Spirit has has given you
right and so at the end of the day they
would see the book as a gift received
from Authority that's what the book is
it's a it's a gift in fact our word
Authority right
has is the same root as author right so
a book is a gift received from Authority
um in the
modern world right with this the
discipline of textual criticism is uh is
used to look for these differences
between texts no matter how minute they
are right and use them to propose
propose new theories why new theories
because people have to write
dissertations you got to get published
right you can't get published saying
something somebody's already said so you
got to come up with a new Theory and so
it's used to propose new theories about
the age authorship Providence of of text
and of course sacred text among them and
at its worst and and obviously this is
again it's a useful discipline
um it's something that I do and engage
in on a regular basis but at its worst
This Modern way of reading sees
differences and difficulties as being
something worse than mistakes right uh
at their accidental tells
that someone is being dishonest with you
that somebody's trying to pull the wall
over your eyes and so there's this idea
that on the one hand the apostles were
these Master con men right these Master
con men they're fooling everybody into
this construct of Jesus of Nazareth that
this new religion they started but then
on the other hand they're so bad at
their job that they didn't notice their
own you know you know they couldn't get
their stories straight right it's just
it's a little obviously I think it's a
little ludicrous right but the
assumptions of this way of reading in
contrast to the pre-modern way of
reading are first of all suspicion right
there's an inherent hermeneutic of
Suspicion the author has an agenda and
then usually this idea that historical
forces uh I say in in my most Marxist
accent possible right uh that economic
political social forces guided
not the Holy Spirit but these forces
these forces guided both the composition
and the transmission of the work and so
the book goes from being
a gift received from Authority and it
becomes a text received from an author
right a text received from an author
received from like patriarchal you know
power yes well that that's really that's
really that's when post-modernism comes
in right and so this this this modern
way of reading focused on uh first and
foremost on authorship it's the most
interesting question because if we can
know when someone lived and what their
social economic circumstances were then
we're better able to understand the
agenda of the text but what
post-modernism does is it comes in it
deconstructs the modern way of reading
further because it assumes uh basically
liquidity
um uh the author is dead right the this
whole death of the office thing the
author is dead and therefore any agenda
that they might have had
you you don't actually need to know or
care about that because this book the
book is now a fluid reality which can be
manipulated to serve to redistribute
social and economic power via various
critical lenses and so this is when you
get into well let's do a a let's do a
post-colonial reading of Beowulf which
is a real thing that somebody has done
you know well did anybody writing
Beowulf have postcolonialism or even
colonialism in mind
yeah but the disease is already there in
the modern things no it is it is yeah
because in the modern way of thinking
what they would want to do is show how
the let's say the the power structure
whether it's from a Marxist point of
view or some something akin to that is
embedded in the text and the fact that
it was Authority authoritative means
that it participated in in maintaining
certain social orders that were
important for the people of the day and
so they'll tend to look into the text
and like to see the preservation like if
you look at some of the Old Testament
title critical writing they see it as a
conflict of different groups and
different political factions
and that there's this like conflict that
you can find inside the text that's
showing a political conflict within
Israel at the time and the big problem
that I am currently having with a lot of
let's say
uh broadly conservative reactions to
post-modernity
is that they are trying to get back to
modernity yeah
and this is this is just it's it's not
far enough right it's not far enough for
us as Christians that's not
that's not an acceptable solution yeah
yeah
um so to talk a little bit about the
idea of like authorship uh the the
authorship in the ancient world was
always understood as as being a a
composite thing
this is part of why like the these these
like modern the modern hyper fixation on
oh well there's this group in the text
and this group of the text like you're
just saying this is like sort of missing
the point from a pre-modern perspective
because uh well first of all putting the
name of an established Authority on a
work let's say for instance the Old
Testament book The Wisdom of Solomon
um uh this was often uh this is a this
is a link with the chain of tradition
right it's not always an absolute
statement about the origin of every
syllable in the works in the case of the
wisdom of Solomon nobody thought that
Solomon wrote wrote it I mean it was
everybody do it had been written much
later
um but they named it that why because
it's in the solomonic wisdom tradition
that goes back to Proverbs you've got
the Proverbs of Solomon did Solomon
write all of the Proverbs of Solomon
according to the Proverbs of Solomon he
did not well but we still call them
and the way that we still call the
Psalms the Psalms of David right David
is the author of The psalter even though
if you in the actual text
he's not the author of every single one
of the Psalms um this is again
this is not a problem for anybody before
the 19th century like nobody cares like
like we understand what we mean when we
say this right uh so if somebody wants
to say
if somebody wants to say there's like a
uh uh you know there's like a little bit
of you know uh oh this later thing was
added to one of the Books of Moses for
instance right well like the description
of his death for example that's right
right yeah which is that someone else
wrote the description of Moses death
right right
whatever who cares
right not is that is that a problem for
anybody no not really right um because
again we the pre-modern uh uh person
trusts that
the holy spirit is guided not just the
process of composition but also the
process of transmission and so this is
even when you get into like
um
there are certain pericapes in The
Gospel According to Saint John
specifically the the one concerning the
woman caught in adultery right which
doesn't show up in some ancient
manuscripts right and so then you could
sort of ask the question well
you know is this originally part of the
Gospel or not and actually for our
purposes it doesn't matter what matters
is uh is that you know this is this is
something at somewhere in the in the
process of transmission right which the
Holy Spirit oversaw this this story is
one of the stories that's in this Gospel
According to Saint John it's in this
yonian tradition and and then you would
just look at well how did how how how
does the church how do we use this you
know liturgically and that sort of will
kind of clear up some of those questions
so
um now sacred texts were copied with a
great deal of fidelity uh but the
farther out you get from Holy Scripture
the more likely there are it is for
major changes to be introduced so a good
example of this in in an essay of his uh
called The Genesis of the medieval book
which is really important essay that I
think everybody's interested in these
things should read C.S Lewis uh uses the
iterations of the Arthurian tales and
you say he starts with just Jeffrey of
Monmouth as an example who just includes
a little bit of King Arthur in his
overall annals right and then uh you've
got
waist and then uh and then lion coming
along and enlarging and massively
improving on what Jeffrey did right and
it was understood that this is sort of
like oh let's say uh uh far enough out
in the north X as it were right you know
near enough to the base of the mountain
that you have the ability to kind of
improve things but also bring in things
that you've heard that the previous
author maybe hadn't and stuff like that
right
um and so the way to think about a
medieval book or a pre-modern book is
that it's a cathedral right
um every great cathedral built in the
Middle Ages was built over the course of
one two in one case 600 years right well
you're gonna start building a building
that is going to be finished by your
grandchildren and great grandchildren
who are going to have totally different
architectural tastes than you you do
right and so these great medieval
Cathedrals a lot of times you'll have
well this bit was done here and this bit
was done at this time and this bit was
done at this time and so everything like
sort of doesn't match but at the same
time it totally goes together right
because it it just sort of grew up in
this organic way right but if you wanted
to try to pick through and pull out and
try to pull out the pieces that that you
could say well this is the original
Cathedral then the building just
collapses right and this is the kind of
the same way that medieval books work um
so Eugene vodolaskin who you've had at
the channel before
um who's uh you know a wonderful
wonderful uh fiction author um I'll Hawk
his new book once again uh uh uh the
history of the island which is actually
a it is a work of you of medieval
Universal history as a novel and it's uh
it's just fantastic so uh people should
go read it but
um he said uh in a really important
essay of his called the Middle Ages he
said that it's important to note that
there's a spectrum here that the
stability of a medieval text depended in
large part on its closeness to the Holy
Scripture the primary book in the Middle
Ages the Holy Scripture the text of
texts standing at the Center of
Spiritual life had a special fate any
new manuscript copy of the Holy
scriptures was produced by drawing not
on one but on two or more manuscripts
the scribes looked after the Integrity
of the Holy text by comparing
manuscripts correcting possible errors
and deviations from the canonical text
at the other end of the spectrum that
ends with maximal distance from the
sacred one can see that the text changed
significantly when reproduced and
everybody was okay with this yeah right
what What mattered wasn't
um so much who says something but what
was said you could say
and so they don't really have in the
Middle Ages they don't really have this
idea of plagiarism and in fact they
don't really have a strong notion of
authorship
um most medieval authors simply did not
sign their work unless they were a very
important person like one of the church
fathers or
um
you know an emperor or something like
that who who had
um like the spiritual or social right to
do so but for most most medieval authors
the idea that you would sign your work
would be seen as kind of like a an act
of pride
so that's the first thing is the shift
in the way that we approach uh that we
approach the question of authorship and
transmission and if we can actually just
make that one shift then 90 of people's
problems and like Hang-Ups and things
like this especially the kind of
Hang-Ups that very smart people tend to
have will go away and then you can
actually start reading the text right
it's the I always crack up whenever like
I buy a new edition of some protistic
text or medieval poem or something like
that and the actual text itself is not
that long it's maybe 80 pages but then
before the before the 80 Pages you have
150 pages of critical analysis of here's
what the guy who put this book together
you know basically this is his PhD
dissertation here's what he thinks about
the text right and it's sort of clear by
volume which thing is the more important
in terms of what's being published
all right so the second thing that I
would want to kind of point out is as a
necessary necessary shift this is a much
shorter Point
um is the meanings of words and things
right
because modernism is a flattening and a
separation of space and time we'll talk
about that a little more in a moment uh
but it also tends to flatten out meaning
as well so as such modernism is usually
capable of understanding something as
either being literal
which by which we mean being understood
as most obvious materialistic sense like
a measurable taxonomical category
usually something like if you had a
camera
yeah right but of course of course this
this itself is a bad test right because
we all know perfectly well uh from
recent events that you can have a camera
on site and half the people watching the
video see what's going on see two
totally different things right you know
yeah um so that during the trucker
protest very clearly yeah it's just
trucker protest uh I mean lots of other
things you know like almost any tragedy
that gets done for political purposes or
whatever somebody will have a video of
what happened and half the people who
watch it see one thing and the other
half who watch it see the other thing
but anyway uh but modern people will uh
uh are usually capable of understanding
something is either being literal or
allegorical which by which they mean
having a symbolic meeting
and that's that's what the thing we you
know we we hit that all the time on the
symbolic world because at the outset
when I started talking about these
things yeah I would just get backlashes
of people saying oh you're saying it's
all allegorical it's all metaphor you
know and I'm like I'm not saying any of
those things but I still remember your
there is no such thing as literal video
yeah yeah
which is like purely medieval like in
the sense that that we're talking about
now which is that they're they're you
know it's like the
this idea of like this objective reality
that is completely neutral of of of
importance it's like even in the modern
world even though we have that category
in the modern world it it falls apart
very fast right and so this is this is I
think one of the things that
um that this one in the next I I would
say the next three things like there are
four things these next three things are
the things that your channel has
probably done the most open people's
eyes on like this this understanding
like if you can just see that things can
mean more than one thing right uh that
words could mean more than one thing but
also that things that that the things
that exist on the world have meaning
they have significance
um uh that you know you can have a tree
right and the tree is you could say in
some in some objective secularist
reality right the the tree is just it's
just an arbitrary organism but actually
even materialists don't usually think
this way because uh because they'll be
oh well you can't trees are good for the
environment right you can't cut down
trees but actually if if we're if we're
doing a secularist materialist devoid of
meaning the tree is just an organism
it's its existence is just as arbitrary
as every other organisms right so unless
I give it meaning there's no reason I
can't cut it down yeah right
um
so medieval people believed um I just
read that quote from but Alaskan uh
because they believe that uh everything
they wrote and read was uh no matter
what its style to some degree a
continuation or a concretization of the
Holy scriptures right because they
believe this they believe that books
could have multiple complementary layers
of meaning a very simple uh uh we just
uh for orthodox Christians
um actually old calendar new calendar
both would have recently finished the
dormition fast so every year doing the
dermission fast my family reads um
the life of the Virgin by Saint Maximus
the Confessor which is his sort of
hagiography of the life of the mother of
God and uh early on in it you know he's
talking about Psalm the 44th Psalm you
know the Queens did it thy right hand
quote then and you know and this is the
this is like one of the primary you know
Psalms one of the primary Old Testament
passages that the church sees and
historically all Christians have seen as
uh as talking about the mother of God
and uh and he says but if you find
somebody who says that the queen in this
passage actually is the church
there's no problem with that because
first of all
she is the church and secondly and then
he says words authored by the Holy
Spirit
ought not to be understood as having
only one meaning
um
wow very very just very very simple
words authored by the Holy Spirit
ought not to be understood as having
only one meaning right
um
and so uh in the Middle Ages this
eventually develops into something that
probably most people who have taken some
kind of a class on like the Middle Ages
or read like Augustine's confed Saint
Augustine's confessions in school or
something like that will be familiar
with and that is the four-fold sense
right uh and there's like there's
actually even fun little Latin mnemonic
poems to help people remember this right
but basically it's the literal uh we
could say historical might be a better
way of of phrasing that right here's
what happened in history right
um although even that is is maybe a
little fraught but let's just say like
this is what happened in history this is
how it was recorded this this is the
event that was recorded right that's
that's what that is then there's the
typological which would be uh uh in what
way does this text uh this story or this
symbol or something like that in what
way does it connect with the Life of
Christ with uh the life of his mother
with the life of the church Etc so a
very good example is something like
um you know the Old Testament the
serpent in the wilderness right the
Brazen serpent well on the historical
level
God told Moses to make a serpent right
this is the literal reading okay God
told Moses to make a bronze serpent he
lifts it up on a pole and everybody who
looks at it or touches it is healed
now
on its own that doesn't actually have a
whole lot of meaning right it's just
here's God gave you instructions to do
an arbitrary thing yeah and I always did
it I always take the literal meaning as
like the way we talk about literally
mean it's just like getting the facts
right right they're just getting this is
what the text says like this right text
says this because one of the problems
with sometimes with with in a negative
sense we call allegorical reading is
that people gloss the text yes they
don't pay attention to it uh carefully
they just kind of gloss over it and then
give this like high meaning but I think
it's really important even in symbolic
interpretation like that you stay that
you get the text right you get 100 you
get everything there right yeah so so in
the in that case here's the historical
event God told Moses to do a thing Moses
did the thing people were healed right
but then there's a typological
significance which has to do with the
lifting up of Christ on the cross uh
this one is is easy because Christ
himself explained it to us right
um which we don't always get we don't
always get
um and then the third level is what
sometimes called the moral or the
tropological level
um and moral as in this is the moral of
the story in other words because this
happened here's how you should behave
right that's the moral of the story
um this is any one of these Levels by
the way is like a fine level but if you
treat it like it's the only one then you
get like an awful version of the story
so for instance uh there's a lot of like
mingling of traditional fairy tales
because people were you know fairy tales
which were not traditionally just
stories for children yeah but in the
Victorian period when they try to make
them into just stories for children
they would always rewrite them with this
sense of and then here's the moral at
the end yeah right and so it's just like
it just like saps the Vitality out of
the story which is actually mostly
happening on the typological level right
um
um and then the finally the fourth level
that that they would see would be was
sometimes called the the anagogical or
the eschatological level which is
basically connecting the text with last
things the end of the world or the end
of a pattern the end of a cycle or most
importantly probably at the end of your
life right
um and uh it's important to note that
people didn't just use these senses to
read the scriptures
yeah they actually use them to read
Homer
and they use them to read everything and
they would actually say you could read
The Odyssey and there's a typological
sense in which you can apply the Odyssey
to the Life of Christ yeah
right and they a hundred percent
sincerely believed that
um and what I'm sort of you know
obviously trying to imply is that you
can do this too you can do it with
something like Lord of the Rings I've
got a whole podcast where that's what we
do
um
so but in the same way uh things can
mean
uh not just words but also themes like
like the things that you encounter in
the world can mean more than one thing
right again rocks trees basic things
like that um uh my favorite example
honestly is is Bread and Wine right you
know part of the whole symbolic literal
argument you know around the the
Eucharist in the Christian you know West
over the last 500 years 600 years now
has has been because
um people sort of see well it can only
be one thing like it can only it can be
bread and the blood and body right at
the same time right you have to like we
have to collapse it to the body and then
make the bread whether they call it like
just like details like like uh yeah
accidents or whatever accidental that's
right that's the word yeah so uh one of
my favorite things that Dante wrote is
actually a series of letters oh I gotta
plug my computer in
um is a series of letters that he wrote
actually explaining the Divine Comedy uh
which is uh which is nice again when the
author like gives you an explanation of
his own thing pay attention he may be
wrong uh you know but but still you
should pay attention so uh what what he
says is that we should call it
that is
um writing polysemus that is of many
senses first sense derives from the
letters themselves a second from the
things signified by the letters we call
the first sense literal so he gives his
own explanation for for this and then he
gives an example from the comedy so to
clarify this method of treatment
consider this verse when Israel went out
from Egypt the house of Jacob from a
barbarous people Judea was made to
Sanctuary Israel his Dominion which by
the way that's the psalm the P that the
souls seeing when they are being brought
to the mountain of purgatory at the
beginning of purgatorio he says now if
we examine the letters alone The Exodus
of the children of Israel from Egypt in
the time of Moses is signified that's
the letter that's the level of the
letter we we call the literal meaning
right in the allegory it's our
Redemption is accomplished through
Christ uh so that's the typological
sense in the moral sense the conversion
of the soul from the grief and misery of
sin to the State of Grace so this is how
I should behave because of this and then
in the anagogical or the eschatological
sense The Exodus of the Holy Soul from
the slavery of this corruption to the
freedom of eternal glory they can all be
called and then he says they can all be
called symbolic right of course he means
something different by that than most of
us mean today but um
and but this is actually how he uses the
psalm in the comedy because if you pay
attention to those early cantos of
purgatory that's actually what is
happening is all four of those things
it's it's you know remembering this time
God delivered his people but also in the
moral sense it's the conversion of
Dante's soul from the grief and misery
of his own sin right and and so on so
that's the that's the second thing that
I would want to help people make this
shift on is that is the meaning of words
and things right and their abilities to
kind of have uh uh that the world itself
is symbolic the world itself is
polysemous and and that these
connections are not arbitrary which is
yeah but they're not arbitrary is very
important because this is something that
we run into with postmodernism which is
that
post-modernism argues for polysemy as
well but they argue for free-floating
polysemy so like the idea is that is
that you have multiple meanings but
those multiple meanings are disconnected
from each other and there isn't let's
say an underlying uh analogy between the
different levels of meanings and so and
interestingly enough is that because of
that when now
people like you and I argue for polysemy
people accuse us of being post-modern
because that's where they've heard that
and they're like well how can it have
several meanings it means that
everything's going to blow up and then
right we don't know what's real and it's
all made up and it's all in your mind
and it's all that but it's like no it's
not it's it's neither of those the the
police the the polythemic aspect of a
text is all directed right it's all
directed towards the truth and that's
what makes the different levels uh
cohere together so when Dante presents
his different levels of what he means by
that Psalm though it it's not they're
not disconnected they're just different
levels of the same meaning uh the
different levels of the same truth and
it's because they had a uh
you say the pattern or the interpretive
map that they're using or
both the book of the scriptures and also
the book of creation right is the
passion and resurrection of Jesus Christ
yeah right that's the central thing uh
that you have to take as completely
um necessary to this entire model right
um that uh without it without it
um almost all Western literature just
becomes incoherent right even fairy
tales even fairy tales most of the the
fairy tales written by The Brothers
Grimm and I'm talking like the first
edition that had all the gnarly stuff in
it before they kind of you know made it
polite later yeah but but the the the
the the
uh all those fairy tales right those
fairy tales
actually have
the gospel story encoded within them
right on the typological level and that
doesn't mean it had to be a deliberate
thing right that this is just you know
uh I am I mean you're you're you're your
thing that you say right this is how the
world lays itself out yeah right this is
this is the way that things are
right and that's really that's really
important because especially and it's
weird because a lot of people have done
the opposite which is to try to make the
fairy tales into non-Christian things
and usually what they they mean by that
is because the the fairy tales are
immoral often actually they aren't
actually they actually aren't usually
about just like uh or whatever they're
quite amoral they're quite mythological
and they can be quite jarring but the
truth is that like read the story of
Samson again I read the Book of Judges
this is actually part of our tradition
you know the idea that everything has to
be clean and moral and and Puritan is
ridiculous it's just not part of the
tradition at all like the the these
gnarly and kind of weird Stories the way
that people read Homer there's there's
very weird stuff in Homer but they could
nonetheless or they could read Plato
people could read the Symposium and even
though it had all this kind of dark
stuff they could see that there were
still glimmers shining through it you
know without having to accept things
this as just being an example of more or
less than about this or that
that's that's beautifully put um
yeah this is this is like this is the
big thing that we gotta people to sort
of understand because even then uh
actually something that's sort of come
up recently now I'm off the reservation
I'm off my notes but uh is is the way
that the way that somebody could read
and be offended by like a saint story
like a work of how geography right
there's like weird sometimes shocking
stuff to Modern sensibilities in the
Saints lives if you don't think that
then you just haven't read enough of
them yeah
um and so this sort of like we have this
kind of idea of here's what like a like
a clean polite well-behaved right
Christian person is supposed to look
like and it's basically the product of
basically it's like the 1950s right yeah
you know like like it's it's like at
least in this country we have like 1950s
America in our head right you know
that's the that's that's our gold that
era so that's where we go back to and
we're like you know this the lawn's got
to be neatly trimmed and uh you know you
know all that stuff and uh man it's it's
you know it just the the tradition is so
much uh uh weirder than that it's so
much more dangerous than that you know
uh uh and uh
um this is you know again this is not to
say
you know I mean nobody nobody who knows
me would think for a moment that I'm you
know running down like the moral
teachings of the church or anything like
that no and nothing like that but but to
say that that actually if you if you go
and look at actually what the tradition
is
you know in literature in the church in
our hagiography in the scriptures all
these things if you look at what it is
it's
not that it's not that just sort of
clean
it's not that just sort of like clean
you know the lawn is perfectly cut and
and
you've got the
two kids one boy and one girl and like
just that whole like sort of black and
white image of here's what perfect life
you know is supposed to be if you're a
good person you go to church on Sundays
um and and uh this is where this is
where fairy tales really fit into things
but they they would have read those
stories
um and they would have read but they
would have also read Homer and they
would have also read even like the the
North Smith right um uh there's some
great work uh that's been written we're
going to talk about it some in the veil
of glass people uh there's been some
great stuff that's written about how
Christians when they you know the
Scandinavian and Germanic Christians
when they converted they were able to
look at things like idrisil right the
tree of life right the world tree right
and then to sort of see it as the cross
right and and then and then develop a
really beautiful poetic tradition around
the cross which is actually deeply
consonant with the Byzantine poetic
tradition around the cross
um so we'll we'll talk about some of
those things in the Beowulf class but uh
just to move on real quick because I
know we're like way over the normal time
for these kinds of things
um the third thing that you need to
understand
um and and again this is something that
you have been trying to tell people and
I think effectively telling people for
years is that heaven is above and hell
is beneath
um the medieval vision of the cosmos is
not geocentric
right that is the world at the center it
is uh rather the Earth at the bottom
right and so you you get this very
clearly in Dante
um where uh you've got
the uh the the uh the outer Heaven the
Empire right where God dwells right uh
the Divine Rose the beauty of everything
sort of like about like reality bounces
back in on itself like a mirror image
and it's God it's centered everything
around him right but then you have these
various tiers the various you know
different Heavens right these different
Heavens uh the heaven uh uh of the fixed
stars and Saturn and uh Joe or Jupiter
and Mars and soul the Sun and Venus and
Mercury and the moon and then beneath
the moon
um and basically in the Middle Ages the
really important barrier is the barrier
of the Moon
right things beneath the moon can change
it's the world of time it's the world
where repentance is possible but it's
also the world where things die and
decay beyond the Moon is things are
fixed and things move in Kind of Perfect
order right
um
and so in in Dante's Divine Comedy when
Lucifer when the devil is cast out of
Heaven he's cast down to earth why is he
cast down to earth and not some other
place which would actually be a
perfectly good question to ask if you
had like a copernican model of the
universe right why not why why Earth
well it's very simple answer and Dot in
in in the the the bottoms it's the
bottom it's as far down as you can go so
Lucifer is cast down to earth and when
he lands his body makes a pit because
basically the Earth hates him and is
trying to get out of his way right so he
lands and everything is like sort of
thrown up and the the dirt is thrown up
on the other side of the planet that
becomes the amount of purgatory uh and
then Satan eventually lands at the
center of the earth why at the center of
the Earth because in this
uh you could say like geography yeah uh
this is as far away as you can get from
God that's the lowest point yeah the
lowest point
so man did Medieval man did not see
himself as standing at the center of the
universe he saw himself as standing at
the bottom of a great stairway looking
up towards God
and of course the uh the the the the the
medieval
uh medieval man understood
the entire human life as the Soul's
elongating a desire to return to God uh
who had made it right and so it's really
easy to remember this if we remember two
things one is that in the Middle Ages
nobody believed the World is Flat uh it
wasn't like people all thought the world
was flat until Christopher Columbus or
whoever sailed around it proved you know
like oh my gosh are there really still
people that think that I die I still run
into it people are like oh Columbus
proved the world was rounded I'm like no
he didn't the Greeks proved the world
was round and they did it with math and
they did it you know 4 000 years ago and
anyway uh but then also the other thing
is the other thing is uh and this here's
my little Ender's Game reference for
Anders game fans out there like we just
remember the enemy's gate is down
um that is that is you know hell is down
right the the center of the earth right
um and so in the medieval cosmology
there's no such thing as outer space
doesn't exist not to say they didn't
know that their stars played as comets
Supernova Etc but there's no such thing
as outer space this vast empty Blackness
where everything is just sort of
arbitrary and Neil deGrasse tysony just
kind of floating out there right um
I actually have a theory about that is
that when we switch to the copernican
model outer space becomes the limits of
the earth it actually flips it inverts
weirdly and and everything that used to
happen on the edge of the of the world
is now projected into outer space if you
watch that movie Gravity it's really
actually wonderful like in terms of that
Cosmic sense it represents outer space
as this like place of death and
strangeness that is outside the bound
world and and and basically like it's
it's related to going into the water
that's why at the end of the movie She's
in this in this thing and she encounters
Saint Christopher and she encounters
like this like weird place where she
doesn't understand Chinese and then
finally she dives into the bottom of the
water and comes out like Resurrection
it's like that's a real good
understanding of what outer space is
really yeah the the you know the one of
the other you know really strong ancient
images
um including for like the um through
Germanic people so we're gonna talk
about this in the Beowulf us
um the way that they they they saw the
world as you know as as midden yard
right the Middle Earth surrounded by the
encircling sea right and there's where
the C is like this is the abyss this is
the thing you can't like God is over
there on the other side somewhere right
that's basically what space became for
us when that switch happened yeah
exactly yeah yep
um so
in this conception of the world the
world moves and is moved by love right
Dante again has this wonderful phrase at
the very end of a comedy uh it's
referring to God as the love that moves
the sun and the other stars
so in in the discarded image CS Lewis
makes a really great point about this he
says that
in the modern world we conceive of a
universe governed by laws right we have
the law of universal gravitation the law
of conservation of energy the second law
of Thermodynamics right
um and
one of the things that basically
post-modernity does is it starts to
break down this vision of the universe
even even at the level like quantum
physics which again this is all stuff
you've talked about
um but it breaks down this this idea of
a world that's like totally governed and
kind of predictable and determinable
governed by laws and now we're actually
saying perception is part of the you
know actually affects you know reality
on a Quantum level you know whatever
that means right uh but it's got no
compelling alternative yeah with which
reality could be Unified
and in the Middle Ages they understood
the world as uh being held together and
moved by love which you could say is is
um held in a world that's actually held
and moved together by attention yeah
right and so um uh Jeffrey Chaucer in
his his uh poem The House of Fame which
is not one of the Chaucer stories that
you read in high school I don't know why
you know I guess it's because the
teenagers we figure teenagers can handle
like the body humor of of the Canterbury
Tales and maybe that'll be more fun for
them uh but in the house of Fame
um which which among other things uh
involves this this man sort of ascending
up through the Spheres right
um it's being you know he's asking
questions about how the medieval
Universe Works the way it does and he's
told that every I'll just quote from it
here every kindly thing kindly as in the
sense of according to its kind not as in
the sense of nice yeah nice so every
everything according to His Kind every
kindly thing that is Hatha kindly stead
that is a home there hey he may best in
it conservative B
um unto which place everything through
his kindly inclining moveth forward to
come to so things move in the universe
things move in the cosmos
by
um by this process of basically
everything trying to get back to where
it belongs so why does water sit on top
of the Earth because water belongs here
and the Earth belongs here if I drop the
stone in water why will it go down
Newton was not the first person to
notice that apples fall from trees or
whatever right you know be like gosh no
one's ever noticed this before you know
but the explanation that they would have
given it was the Apple Falls because
it's made of Earth and it's trying to
get back to where it came from
and of course Lewis I'll give another
Lewis quote he says we could ask the
medieval scientists this is silly why
are you talking this way do you really
think that a rock really loves the Earth
like whatever and he would we could
retort or he could retort with a counter
question but do you intend your language
about laws and obedience any more
literally than I intend mine about
kindly inclining in other words is there
like a cosmic traffic court where if you
disobey the law of gravity like you get
a ticket like how is how does this work
how does this work but what Lewis says
is that on the imaginative and emotional
level it makes a great difference
whether we with the medievals uh we
project upon the Universe
um our strivings and desires or with the
moderns our police system and our
traffic regulations like what do you
want to live in uh a cosmic police State
uh which is even affected the ways that
we think about Christianity like the
reduction of Christianity to basically
just moralism yeah
um I mean I've talked about this
elsewhere but I grew up in this you know
fundamentalist group or sect that among
other things believe that
the Bible is a set of laws of the set of
principles what they called them and if
you live by these things then your life
will go well and that they're as
immutable and as provable as like the
law of gravity I mean they would have
said that
right and so uh do we want to live in a
world in a cosmos that's governed by
love or or in one that's essentially a
police state
all right so the last thing I want to
talk about is space and time
um so I'm going to read here a quote
from zigmund Bauman's liquid modernity
which is a an incredible book if people
haven't read it um it uh by liquid
zigmund Bauman means that it is uh
modernity can't hold a shape it can't
hold form
so he says that modernity starts when
space and time are separated from living
practice and from each other and so
become ready to be theorized as distinct
and mutually independent categories of
strategy and action when they cease to
be as they used to be in long pre-modern
centuries the intertwined and so barely
distinguishable aspects of the living
experience locked in a stable and
apparently invulnerable one-to-one
correspondence when I read this
paragraph I was just like oh it's
Matthew's book and it's like everything
Jonathan has been saying for years it's
like but somebody else somebody else is
saying it
um
so modernity basically is the separation
of space and time it's becoming two sort
of separate things right
and I think that you can tell me what
you think about this because I'm still
kind of noodling on this idea but I
think at post-modernity could be
understood as a further Corruption of
this that once space and time are
measured separated categorized they
eventually cease to have any meaning at
all and then we deconstruct them in
order to kind of show how absurd they
are right um I think about this a lot
when I'm driving around in my car
because like it's the most absurd sort
of separation of space and time the fact
that I can be somewhere you know 100
miles away I can be there in an hour and
a half yeah well for sure the the
technology has made this problem
excessively great in the same way that
in your car you have that experience we
have the experience now like look at
what we're doing right now right yes
right yeah there's there's nothing
important like break nothing would
breaks this sense of space as this Zoom
conversation you know yeah that's a good
point I think that I think that um
deconstruction is at its heart it's a
reaction to this absurdity and it's like
a it's like an immune response
um I mean I mean uh this is I did not
intend today to be the day that I've
explained why the metric system was
embedded by demons but
um the the but but but but uh uh as you
know here in America we stubbornly
refuse
I'll measure things in Universal
standard giraffes before I use the
metric system like like oh that's three
giraffes long like I'll I'll go there
before I before I succumb to the use of
the metric system but I mean the but if
you think about the metric system
basically the idea is hey let's measure
the Earth yeah at a certain point that
we've arbitrarily determined let's
measure everything yeah and then divide
it up into regular sections and that's
going to be our base unit of measurement
from now on and it used to be like a
certain piece of metal that they had to
keep at a certain temperature because
actually if you get it out in the real
world it'll stop being that precise
length and now I think they use like
lasers or something but
anyway the the point it's really
important what you're saying because
this is you know the the
the the traditional way of measuring
which is clunky and it's difficult is
nonetheless based on human experience
it's clunky and difficult but it's also
easy and intuitive yeah right uh at a
very base level to say how many feet is
this well I've got a foot I can check
right and and most of the time that's
going to be good enough for most most
applications right
um uh an inch right well I've got it
right it's a cubit I've got an arm uh
you know
um uh but but even like measurements of
time like like so many people have tried
to monkey with the way that we measure
time and it's like like we'll we'll let
you do the metric system with space but
when like no Evolution when they tried
to introduce like the 10-day week you
just can't do it you just can't do it
like everybody has a seven day week like
it's it's completely you know uh it's
one of the most immutable things about
The Human Experience yeah and I mean
just separating time into four quadrants
of sun and dark like light and darkness
and sun and moon even so in in in the
the let's say over the variation it
changes it's like you just can't change
you just can't change that right yes
it's yeah so it's this but this is this
is the the kind of ways that you this
sort of idea that if we sort of measure
and quantify everything yeah right then
we we can control it and then everything
is certain right this this basic idea
what it what it does is it separates
time from space right because it
separates space from any kind of
experience of that space in a way that
you know human beings would use it
um so what father father Silvio bunta uh
in his uh this is in from his his
commentary on the erraticon which is
like for people it's like the priest
book uh from the Seminoles Petro
Monastery on Mount ethos
um
he says that um
uh he talks about how the Orthodox
tradition we have two different words
for time
we have Chronos
you know once chronology right this is
what father Alexander schmerman Called
Death in other words it's the it's
experience of time and Decay right the
linear passage of moments and then we
have Kairos
and Kairos is this uh
uh this this
it's the Eternal moment right yeah it's
qualified it's qualified time it's like
yes qualified time is it good yeah
so uh uh Charles Taylor in a secular age
he describes chironic time as uh how
something that happened 2000 years ago
can become closer to you than something
that happened yesterday so like if you
go to Orthodox posca right which even if
you're not Orthodox like it's not even
close to your Easter this year so like
you have no excuse go go find an
Orthodox Church
like go find out what that's like
um when you go to Orthodox posca you are
experiencing the resurrection as an
event that is closer to you today than
the moon landing or the assassination of
JFK or
um said you know the the you know you
know the the 2016 election or something
like that
I don't know why I couldn't pick a
non-controversial historical event but I
just just file them up there my mind
wouldn't do it um
okay so
um
chronological time is the time of this
world right but the chirotic time the
the Kairos this is this is a time that
knows no chronology
um
a uh uh and what uh and but we have the
same thing actually with space as well
which I think is not as well known in
the Orthodox tradition we have two words
for space there is Cora which means like
normal space like any any old space and
then topos right which means like a
particular place yeah like that's
qualified space too it's like it's like
that it's like this this yeah there's a
hierarchy too it's to its existence so
in the liturgy
Chronos becomes Kairos and space becomes
place
right and all of these things are kind
of caught up into that Eternal moment
um and to give like an example of this
so this is all by by way of saying not
only is the metric system demonic uh but
cause and effect is made up
um in the Middle Ages people did not see
history and again you could read some of
vodolaskin's uh essays about this and
he's even got a whole section on it in a
history of the island if people are
curious about this but in the Middle
Ages people didn't see history as a a
series of cause and effects causes and
effects they saw history as a battle
between good and evil
which means that the most important
thing that history has already happened
because that was the crucifixion and the
resurrection of Jesus Christ yeah right
but history is this battle between good
and evil this is what the whole
Apocalypse of Saint John is about is
history seen as this conflict between
good and evil in which good ultimately
triumphs but because we see history in
this way
um if we uh you know if if I slap
Jonathan or let's say I insult Jonathan
I say something really mean about your
mother right and then you slap me right
we could say well there's a cause which
is I said something insulting and in
fact which is you slap me but in the
Middle Ages they wouldn't have
understood it this way they would have
understood it as I sinned against the
image of God in you or your mother and
that God through your hand punished me
right that's the that's the sort of
difference there's a we see sort of
histories being this flat
two-dimensional thing but they they
would have seen God is constantly always
intervening in history and where this
becomes really important is when you
understand something like the
enunciation
so if you only have this Chrono this
understanding of chronological time in
which everything must proceed through a
course a series of ordinary cause and
effects or something Lewis really
struggled with when he was writing
Miracles and he actually kind of had to
go back and revise quite a bit of it
after
um after a conversation with a Roman
Catholic philosopher on the subject okay
but um if you see history as just being
the series of sort of normal causes and
effects
then Mary is an ordinary Jewish girl one
whose life must have gone on in the
usual way marriage childbirth Family
Life old age death as part of a part of
a normal succession of cause and effect
and so you'll have conversations with
somebody who talking about something
like the entrance of the theotogo from
the temple which is an event that we
celebrate in you know that most
traditional all traditional Christians
celebrate and most Christians around the
world celebrate
um as a feast in the church but then
you'll have a modern person come along
and say well that's not they never let
women into the temple so that couldn't
have happened well listen brother
nobody's saying that this is a normal
thing that happened it's not the point
that's why it's a miracle that's why
it's very special that we're talking
about it right and so it but if you see
time is only in this way
then the enunciation and the Incarnation
become like a blip or an interruption
into the ordinary passage of things
which is otherwise just part of the
linear progress of humanity
but if you view it as uh as happening in
a chirotic time it's happening in Kairos
then all of the righteous actually from
across human history Adam Seth Noah
Abraham David right sort of narrow into
a point so that by the time that uh the
word is incarnated in the womb of the
most holy virgin
um there's basically just the one
righteous family left in Israel right
and but it's all from a Kronos
standpoint that's terrible because look
you know by a number standpoint bad guys
are winning right but actually from in
terms of Kairos no it's everything is
distilling everything's condensing down
to a single point so that all of God's
interventions on behalf of his people
throughout history are actually rolled
up into and made manifest in that moment
and this is why the uh The Magnificat
which is one of the oldest Christian
hymns a lot of historians think that it
was already being sung in church before
the old before The Gospel According to
Saint Luke was actually written right
it's one of the oldest Christian hymns
this is why The Magnificat if you look
at it it's really like a bringing
together of every song of a Victorious
righteous woman from the Old Testament
so you can look at uh Deborah's song and
Miriam's song of the Sea and the song of
the righteous Hannah and like like all
of their prayers right uh you know as
the as the weaker person praying for
deliverance right all of that stuff is
kind of rolled up into that single
prayer that that she prays
um
and so this is where we get to this idea
that I think would be like the fifth and
final or the the fourth and final maybe
go ahead just tell people see what what
Richard is is alluding to is in some
ways there's a man in which you can
understand the let's say the
the enunciation of Mary as the cause of
all the other ones that came before
in in in in in a sense of meaning right
it's like that's what that's what
Richard is trying to allude to and
that's why when we talk about it's like
that which makes all those other things
worthy of interest and important to
notice and strings them together and
makes them something is is is actually
something that happens after the event
and that is
you know and and that's why in some ways
like Christians have an eschatological
vision of reality yeah which is also
that that which will happen in the
future like the the the ascaton that's
coming over the hill that never quite
happens is going to make sense of
everything and will show us and will
reveal to us what the cause of
everything was in the first place and
there's a collapse between the end and
the beginning when some ways the end
becomes the beginning or the beginning
and the end are brought into the person
of Christ as this glorious figure that
is both the one that comes at the end
but then revealed to be the one that
created is the Lamb of God that was
sacrificed before the foundation of the
world although that happened at the
crucifixion that might sound like a
weird
a weird way of thinking but it it
actually is something that we experience
all all the time that we experience in
our lives all the time which is that the
fact that we remember things in our past
as being important is usually based on
things that are happening to you now and
that things that are culminating for you
now it's like oh the reason why I liked
to I like to to to play this game when I
was young is because oh it turns out I'm
going to become a doctor or whatever and
we kind of and it's weird because the
post-moderns it's something that they
understood
he wrote this little book called
postmodernism explained to children
and that was his definition of
postmodernism post-modernism was
basically reinterpretation of the past
based on the present but again what the
postmoderns got wrong is that they saw
it as an arbitrary exercise in power
ultimately which is that there's a way
in which power can now reinterpret the
past and make it align with with with
their present vision and they didn't
have a sense in which none of this is
actually arbitrary and ultimately all of
this is is playing in in Cosmic patterns
that are that are true that are just
simply true and are playing out in in in
creation you could say that
post-modernism is sort of a failure of
eschatology right you don't have the
capacity for an eschatological Vision
you just you sort of like you're
reacting against the separation of space
and time but you still you still accept
the the the the Chronos the the fact
that things are just going to keep going
right yeah well had this idea he called
it open eschatology and it's an
interesting idea because he understood
in some ways that the future is coming
to towards us and interpreting the past
but he didn't want like he he he was
like no it's not about saying come Lord
Jesus he would just say come
like just basically you know the the
this this desire to see the future roll
on us but you know it's like that the
world actually does go through does
actually does actually manifest in
patterns and I'm sorry to tell you and
so so it's not it's not arbitrary at all
what's coming over the hill
yes yes so this this kind of brings us
to like the final thing that I want to
say which is that the goal of this kind
of reading and the goal of again my
whole goal
I mean it's really it was like when we
sat down and we first started talking
about doing the universal history series
it was kind of like how do we get people
to take this stuff seriously right
um it's this this idea that that
um
uh
to through these stories and through
sort of helping people understand these
patterns through stories right to help
them have a relationship with the cosmos
that is you could say like a
mystogogical vision of the cosmos right
the Mystic being the relationship
between you could say the Earthly Temple
and the Heavenly Temple right and and
actually in Judaism and in traditional
Christianity those are actually the same
thing there's no distinction between
them
um and so this this uh this is a vision
of a cosmos in which we see that the
relationship between the scene and the
Unseen is is real it's not just merely
symbolic it is symbolic but it's not
merely symbolic in the way that you know
in a way that makes it arbitrary right
yeah and that's the next thing is just
it's not arbitrary you can't say this
enough right the patterns by which the
example you've used sometimes right is
that the patterns by which the cosmos is
laid out aren't just things that we are
making up any more than we see an
arbitrary of a arrangement of pigments
on a canvas and we describe we decide
that they're a van Gogh painting right
um uh but it's also apocalyptic
um and this is what I think sometimes
people miss a little bit
um uh in some of the conversations that
I've seen you know happening in various
circles around the internet talking
about some of the stuff uh that it's
apocalyptic in the original sense you
know of lifting up the veil lifting the
lifting of a veil right that the nature
of this relationship is constantly
revealing itself in man who is a
microcosm
of the universe and then also first and
foremost in the Liturgy right so and
that's the final thing is that this this
relationship between the scene and the
Unseen is liturgical that the
relationships between these things
aren't static they move they dance as in
the Liturgy
um and I still remember the first time I
ever went to a Divine Liturgy and uh uh
you know I I done my homework I'd read
on things ahead of time because that's
how I am and then I got there and
despite the fact that I had read you
know description after description of
what was going to happen in The Divine
Liturgy and I'm there and it's like this
big Festa liturgy and there's a bunch of
clergy and the coming in at the altar
and they're going out of the Altar and
they're doing I'm like I have no idea
what is happening but I had this deep
conviction
in that moment that
this is the shape of everything right
and then of course for us ultimately the
revelation of Jesus Christ the God man
who is himself
the total revelation of God and the
total revelation of the human person and
uh and that's the last thing the last
point is if you're gonna understand the
scripture is if you're gonna understand
the Liturgy if you're gonna understand
any work of pre-modern literature you
have to see man as a microcosm that is
as a little Cosmos right that this
vision of the world is not
anthropocentric man at the center but it
is anthropocosmic
um we are not just a collection of cells
any more than a temple is a collection
of bricks or the Liturgy is just a
collection of arbitrary historical
movements that are created over time
um and this is Again by the way like
there are certain
certain like let's say Circles of
conservatism that are currently trying
to wage war against The Madness of our
of our current age by reducing things so
I saw uh this headline a few weeks ago
um in in like a conservative website
about about some transgendered person
right and so to say but and and they
said but every DNA of this person's you
know biology is is male you know and uh
but listen folks if we are reducing
identity down to Cellular level down to
DNA yeah right we've actually already
seeded the ground to materialism yeah
right because that's why C.S Lewis says
it it has this wonderful quote and uh I
think it I forget in which book of the
the Don Shredder no I'm talking about in
the space Trilogy he says he says gender
is more primarily than sex and it's like
and I quote it on Twitter and everybody
was I saw somebody was enraged you were
like losing the money thinking that I'm
like agreeing with gender Theory because
they want to collapse gender and sex
together which is actually not a
traditional thing at all gender and sex
in traditional uh cultures has always
been different but the problems that
they're not free-floating right right
they are coherent and they are they they
play different they play the pattern of
the same thing at different levels and
you just if we it's hard for people to
think that way but that's just how it is
boats are female
yeah boats are feminine there's nothing
you can do about it um yeah
um another score I thought the three
this is we're gonna go but to paraphrase
something he says in the voice of on
Shredder if you're talking about DNA
that's not what a man is it's only what
he's made of right yeah uh so Archbishop
Dimitri who's uh our our beloved uh uh
uh founder of our diocese here in the OC
the Diocese of the South he said uh that
you know during the first Millennium
since Christ the church was occupied
with the question who is Christ they're
the second with what is the church is
when you have the Schism the great
system the reformation and so on and
that the great question of the third
millennium is going to be what is man
right but Archbishop Dimitri said that
Jesus Christ is the answer right he says
that Jesus Christ is the truth about God
and the truth about man since he is both
God and man God's real nature is
completely revealed in the Son of God
the Incarnate Word and the whole truth
about man his worth his value and
dignity are realized and made manifest
to man in the son of man
Jesus of Nazareth
so this is the the first thing that we
have to really understand and to read
and understand ancient medieval
literature liturgy all of our scriptures
and we absolutely must understand if we
are going to even start to talk about
salvation and what what that means is
that man is a microcosm
um just a couple of quotes to finish
this up saint makaris of Egypt said the
heart itself is only a small vessel yet
dragons are there lions are there there
are poisonous beasts and all the
treasures of evil there are rough and
uneven roads there are precipices but
there too is God and the angels life is
there and the kingdom there too is light
and there are the apostles and the
Heavenly cities and the treasuries of
Grace all things lie within that little
space
and this is why actually this is why uh
in the Orthodox spiritual tradition we
talk about going down into your heart
right like turning the eye of the heart
inward upon itself it's not an act of
just like self-preoccupation but it's
actually because the entire world is
there and that's why uh that's why you
could have somebody who is a Hermit who
is actually upholding the whole world
right because by praying and this is
uh the athenite once corrected somebody
uh for for saying you know Lord Jesus
Christ Son of God have mercy on me and
on the whole world I said don't don't
pray that way just say have mercy on me
The Sinner because if you do that then
you're praying for the whole world right
this really you can't ask God for
anything more than that uh the way that
Saint Maximus the Confessor
phrases in this is he says that the
church building uh that the temple but
he means like the building the physical
building is a human being and every
human being is a church and then he
actually says and the cosmos is a human
being and every human being is the is a
cosmos and the scriptures Are a Human
Being right and every human being is a
scripture
right
um and uh you know from there there's a
lot that we could say about his
mystogical vision uh which I think we're
just like way over time so I'm not going
to do that but
um if you sort of like take these these
five things
right then you can use them to to sort
of
understand when you come to liturgy or
when you come to an ancient text like
Beowulf and we'll talk about this uh in
the class
when you come to uh even something like
the scriptures and you come across
something that's like offensive to your
modern sensibilities
um coming to the church
and you see there's this big wall
between you and the altar
right why is that there like are you
trying to keep me from God what's going
on like I thought the curtain of the
temple was was torn in too you know and
and you know to that we would just say
it was and and when do you show that in
your liturgy because if you wait here in
a minute you'll see it you know uh but
uh if if you come across these if you
come across something that's so
offensive to Modern sensibilities like
monasticism like the relationship
between the the active and the
contemplative life
um
you know why can't you know I'm a
visitor to your church why wouldn't you
let me back in the altar area you know
things like that and these are all real
questions by the way that that I've I've
tried to answer and had to answer for
catech humans and inquirers in my own
Parish right but if we can understand uh
if we can understand that the world is
laid out in this way we can understand
the human body that's first and foremost
a temple of the Holy Spirit right
um
if that's our beginning point then uh we
can go from there to address not just uh
be the good kind of Taurus but also as
Christians address the passions and the
pathologies of our day so this is kind
of my my elevator pitch my really really
long elevator ride pitch for uh if you
can kind of shift the way that you're
thinking about these different things
then okay you won't I can't make you
into like a native of the Middle Ages
although maybe it's more possible than
some people think but uh I can't I can't
I can't make you into a native of the
Middle Ages but what you could do is to
become the good kind of tourist who when
you come to these things and when you
come to these Services right and I'm
really big about don't just read about
this stuff you got to go to church guys
um when you come when you encounter
these things instead of this big weird
or foreign or Eastern you can start to
see actually what's going on there
underneath the surface so anyway I'm
gonna stop repeating myself now all
right Richard thanks this is great uh
and people yeah go sign up for the for
for bail if I really can't wait it's
going to be it's going to be a lot of
fun and we're also we're going to figure
out a way for people to be able to ask
questions to participate where yeah
moderated interactive discussion and a
bunch of really cool stuff I'm excited
about it because there are things that I
can say to the symbolic World crew about
Beowulf that I probably couldn't say in
a more academic setting you know uh
people just wouldn't know how to receive
it or accept it but you guys have been
coming along with Jonathan on this
journey for so many years and and also
with me like I I we've been doing
Universal history for more than two
years now like that's insane so the
groundwork has been you know been laid
so we should be able to just kind of get
right into it so I'm excited about it
and I look forward to seeing everybody
in September all right everybody we'll
talk to you soon bye-bye